Donald J Trump has become the 45th
president elect of the United States I
can't believe I just said that it's
almost impossible to talk about Trump
without talking about controversy about
them insults the lies the bigotry but if
you take those away for even just a
moment
what has he actually promised to do to
make America great again Trump received
a major backlash when he proposed a
totally impactful wall along the
us-mexico border on day one we will
begin working on an impenetrable
physical tall powerful beautiful
southern border wall which he says he'll
get Mexico to pay for right he's also
threatened to deport 11 million
undocumented immigrants which is a lot
but even half wouldn't be totally unreal
since President Obama has deported more
than 2 million people during his eight
years more than any other president
Trump has also put the Affordable Health
Care Act or Obamacare in his crosshairs
when we win on November 8th
can elect a Republican Congress we will
be able to immediately repeal and
replace Obamacare hastily he's
criticized Obamacare for increasing the
cost of health care and promised to
replace the Affordable Care Act with
health care savings accounts he wants
States to devise their own Medicaid
programs to cover the pork various non
partisan groups predict his policies
could leave upwards of 20 million people
uninsured Trump's also been a fierce
critic of the North American Free Trade
Agreement or NAFTA I'm going to tell our
NAFTA partners that I intend to
immediately renegotiate the terms of
that agreement to get a better deal
Trump argues that America is getting
ripped off on trade deals but some say
that trade policies that he's promised
to pursue could send the United States
into a recession he's pledged to impose
tariffs on goods from China and Mexico
but this could easily set off a trade
war which would hit the US economy hard
when it comes to criminal justice Donald
Trump wants the u.s. to get a lot
tougher you know the kind of tough on
crime rhetoric from the 90s we have a
situation where we have our inner cities
african-americans Hispanics are living
in hell because it's so dangerous you
walk down the street you get shot you
see Donald Trump has blamed communities
of color when it comes to gun violence
and in order to reduce it Trump has
proposed bringing back stop and frisk
even though the policy was ruled
unconstitutional and embraces he's also
advocated for stronger police protection
and criticized a reduction of mandatory
minimums for nonviolent offenses so
there you have it those are just some of
the things Donald Trump will offer as
president and if you're interested this
Canadian has no tan line on her ring
finger